foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
in this video I will be showing you why
so many former Game of Thrones fans are
dead wrong about the show as you all
know the final season of Game of Thrones
was arguably one of the most divisive
endings in television history even now
four years after the ending of Game of
Thrones many naysayers will have you
believe the fandom is dead because they
will say things like no one discusses
the show anymore whenever I see them say
that I feel like they're either lying or
it's out of ignorance because they don't
realize how massive Game of Thrones
still is not only is Game of Thrones
still alive but it's still one of HBO
Max's most successful shows on their
service now we all remember how the
ending of Game of Thrones had most of
the fandom divided many fans hated how
Game of Thrones ended myself included
but there are still millions of fans who
love what happened during that final
season however about four years ago
right as the show was ending I started
to see a narrative online on social
media stating that Game of Thrones and
its incredibly massive fan base would be
gone for good even now in the second
half of this year here I still
occasionally see this narrative online
and under my very own videos I think
it's hilarious and ironic whenever that
happens considering they're leaving
these sort of messages under my videos
where I'm discussing the very thing they
say no one is interested in anymore what
makes it even funnier is the fact that
these messages only end up sparking a
new debate about the same show they say
no one is discussing after the ending
now back when the show first ended it
was very easy for many fans to buy into
this sort of thinking because of how
divisive Game of Thrones final season
was none of us had to look very far to
see a dozen new videos about Game of
Thrones awful ending and how it would
lead to its fan base slowly dying off
now that four years have gone by is this
really the case is the Game of Thrones
franchise really over for good well for
us ride or die fans we know that answer
is obviously no but like I said there
are still a lot of former fans who want
you to believe Game of Thrones is dead
and gone forever I guess they must have
forgot what is dead may never die now
now I want to have a look at the numbers
because I think they indicate just how
massive The Game of Thrones brand really
is these numbers might even shock some
of you as well now for example parrot
analytics is a site that monitors the
demand of different shows according to
several different Outlets online this is
one of the many websites that shows Game
of Thrones has remained as one of the
biggest shows on television years after
its final season not only that but Game
of Thrones still has better numbers than
some of the more newer and relevant
shows a year after Game of Thrones ended
in 2020 it won the analytics award for
most in-demand show in that year in the
following years parrot analytics
adjusted the rules to the yearly Awards
to include only shows that came out in
the same year so Game of Thrones wasn't
eligible back then however According to
some of the different websites who also
have analytics during the following
years Game of Thrones remained as one of
the top 10 shows it even beat out some
of the more recent shows that you would
expect would make better numbers
according to what social media says says
only last year if you look at the United
States TV demand versatile Market
average Game of Thrones was still number
one now if you look at these same
analytics for this year during last
month Game of Thrones was number three
that's incredible if you ask me this is
nearly 3 000 days after Game of Thrones
aired its final episode now an even more
accurate way to know whether Game of
Thrones is still relevant or not was
when HBO launched its first successor
show to the original series the demand
for the first season of House of the
Dragon would have ultimately determined
how much interest the general audience
still has in the Game of Thrones brand
and the results did not let any of us
down according to HBO House of the
dragon's first episode had roughly 10
million viewers the biggest HBO Premiere
at that time I think if anything it
shows the interest in the Game of
Thrones franchise and brand certainly
still exists and the show's fans want
more regardless of how divisive the
final season of the show was the ratings
for House of the Dragon remain great
throughout the entire season and it even
won the go Golden Globe Award for best
drama series that's something the
original Game of Thrones show was never
able to do now this does of course say a
lot more about House of the dragon's Own
Strength but it also shows the Game of
Thrones brand is as strong as ever if
Game of Thrones did fall off like many
fans want you to believe do you really
think HBO would want to make other shows
set within this universe not only have
they already green lit a new show about
Duncan egg but they're also developing
other shows and even a movie about aegon
and his Sister Wives as well as a series
about Jon Snow once again it just goes
to show you that Game of Thrones is
Alive and Well now let's have a look at
some of these other numbers because I
think they're interesting as well if you
look at the top shows on HBO alone for
last year you will see Game of Thrones
was still number one beating out
Euphoria and even House of the Dragon
there's a number of different metrics
that will show you Game of Thrones is
still one of the biggest shows out there
even according to Amazon's best sellers
list Game of Thrones is still in the top
10 best-selling TV shows of each ever
since it ended and if you look on the
other side of the law it was also the
most illegally downloaded show during
the lockdown there are still discussions
every day about the show all over Reddit
as well as all the massive fan accounts
on Facebook and Instagram this has even
shown whenever any of the Game of
Thrones actors sit down for interviews
the interview hardly ever wants to ask
them about anything new that they're
working on everyone is still interested
in asking them about what it was like
working on Game of Thrones or their life
after let's face it the numbers speak
for themselves in the four years since
Game of Thrones ended it has remained as
one of the most successful shows on
television only a few days ago if you
were to look at what are the most
watched shows right now Game of Thrones
is number five the funny thing is these
numbers indicate that the show with one
of the most divisive endings in history
still has fans discussing it years later
even more than other shows that left
Their audience 100 satisfied the success
of the show really does speak for itself
it has won dozens of awards it still has
a major fan following with a number of
successor shows either on TV already or
under development at HBO its influences
on the television landscape and on
culture in general and apparently also
its longevity shows that it's a winner
on nearly all fronts even with its bad
ending I still think it's the greatest
series ever made but generally speaking
I think it's safe to say this show is
for the ages and I think it will be
remembered for a long time as one of the
greatest cinematic Works ever created
now I could go on and on showing you a
lot of different reasons why Game of
Thrones is still alive and well but I
think I've said enough already I do know
most of you already understand this
which is why you're still showing love
to my videos because let's be honest we
still love the Show and The Song of Ice
and Fire novels it's based on Game of
Thrones has shown it's one of the
biggest shows ever made and whether some
of us like it or not it's here to stay
now I want to give a shout out to we
Thrones for Gathering all of this
information and organizing it in their
article if you would like to read
everything in full and see a hell of a
lot more evidence I will have that link
Down Below in my description and if you
ever see anyone else saying Game of
Thrones Is Dead feel free to send them
this video link maybe that will shut
them up as always I want to thank all of
you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]